is kmus LA or kmus run a traditional
parade started in Austria where the
adults dress up in realistic kmus
costumes and run through the streets
trying to scare the children into
behaving ahead of the arrival of Kampus
and sa according to history.com Austrian
men would get drunk and run through the
streets dressed as the Fearsome creature
this account from travel dudes.com
mentions 400 gruesome creatures whipping
the legs of children and stealing hats
in freezing cold temperatures some
celebrations also feature women dressing
up as perta another mythological being
in Alpine folklore a goddess who was
associated with the winter solstice just
like Kampus